all right guys
bang bang i've got max here with me
thank you so much for doing this my
friend
thank you for having me absolutely let's
just jump right into it
um you are one of the founders of money
on chain i think a lot of people have
probably heard about it
they know it's something related to
bitcoin but they probably don't
understand
uh exactly what you guys are building uh
and so let's just start kind of
philosophically
uh who you are why you're attracted to
bitcoin and then why are you spending
all of your time which is your most
valuable asset building money on chain
well i am max kakusa uh i discovered
bitcoin like
in 2009 uh
i thought like everybody else i thought
that the blockchain is great but there
is no value in bitcoin
then i rediscovered bitcoin uh
late 2011 and i went through the rabbit
hole
um i've been teaching people about
bitcoin in argentina since 2013.
um well i'm actually a
bitcoiner and when
federer appears
immediately it brought my attention
the problems with a centralized
stablecoin
there are basically two big problems
with uh
with that kind of stable coin the first
one is that
when you go into feather or usbc or
another centralized stable coin
you have to trust the company behind
that and
there is not too much bitcoin and the
second problem is that
when you go to a stable coin like
ucc or you are actually selling your
bitcoin
for dollars so um
the the idea behind money and chain was
having a stable coin for bitcoiners
that inherits the same properties of
bitcoin that
no one can um
you can transact with everybody and and
and no one can stop your transaction
that that was the
first idea behind manual chain and
having
the bitcoin as collateral i consider
bitcoin as the best quarter
you can have but moreover when you
have a stable coin like money and chain
you are not actually selling your
bitcoin you are parking your no
you're not selling your bitcoin for
dollars you're parking your dollars in a
smart contract so there is no
cell pressure in the market
got it and so really the idea here was
uh you were attracted to bitcoin for all
the reasons that everyone is attracted
to bitcoin
uh but you realize that there was going
to be value in the stablecoin market
um and it sounds like you were uh
against the idea of hey sell my bitcoin
for
dollars to then have a dollar back
stable coin and so really that first
foray was how do i build a stable coin
using bitcoin as the collateral
but still enjoy all the things around
censorship resistance
um and kind of non-custodial nature of
uh some sort of financial product but
get stable value that i could then
transact back and forth
exactly uh we think that
there are a lot of use cases for bitcoin
for example companies
transacting with each other and people
buying the pizza but that is not
happening because of the volatility of
bitcoin
most bitcoiners think that bitcoin
volatility
will go away i think that bitcoin
volatility
won't go away because we have been using
gold for
5000 years and the gold is still
volatile
yeah and so one of the things that's
really really interesting about your
approach
is you essentially uh see the value
of the ideas that many people are
talking about outside of bitcoin whether
it's stable coins or
derivatives or earning yield or you know
whatever other idea
your whole point and i think why you
guys are focused on um
the the mechanism that you're focused on
is those are great ideas
but they should be built on top of
bitcoin using all of the
kind of benefits that a secure
decentralized censorship resistant chain
would provide
rather than give up those qualities in
order to pursue
faster transactions or cheaper fees or
some other kind of innovative
um you know type of uh edge case on the
technology
exactly you don't have to give away
the using of the best collateral to have
all that you you can have all that on
top of bitcoin
got it and so when you think about uh
what you're building
is this a layer two is it a side chain
does it actually not matter what we call
it like walk us through some of the
technical architecture here
um so that people understand exactly
what's happening when let's say they use
uh this kind of bitcoin collateralized
stablecoin okay
today this is more like a layer three
because we are building this on top of
rsk
rsk is a sidechain of bitcoin that use
uses most of the miners of bitcoin
through a process called merge mining
and we have built this
protocol of set of protocols on top of
rsk
we build a manual chain to bring
the file to the bitcoin world and to
bring bitcoin to the masses
um we have more than just a stablecoin
protocol we have a stablecon protocol
we have a decentralized oracle protocol
that is very important for
decentralization
um we have a governance protocol
and we have also a decentralized
exchange protocol
and when you go ahead so you you
can build the finance 2.0
on top of money on china got it
so we've got the bitcoin blockchain
which is kind of layer one
we then have rsk which provides smart
contract capabilities using this merge
mining
uh as a side chain to that or kind of a
layer two replacement if you will
and then you've got money on chain built
on top of rsk so that's where you get
kind of that layer three
application if you will uh when you
start when you start to think about
who's using this is this crypto native
folks who
come in and say look i've got bitcoin i
want to start to uh
put it to work in certain ways or is
this actually folks that are outside of
the industry
that are becoming bitcoin or crypto
natives because they see these products
they want to use the product so where is
the usage coming from
well basically both worlds we have
four tokens we are going to focus
in the first two um the tolerant chain
that is the stable coin
and the bit pro that is a liquidity
token for
bitcoin holders so the the tolerance as
i told you is a stable coin
is uh is backed by bitcoin the pay is
warranted by the smart contract that is
very important
you don't depend in secondary markets
the bank
is warranted by the smart contract you
can always within your dollar and change
against the smart contract
and then we have this second token that
is called the big pro
that is the token that i like more that
is a liquidity token meant
for beacon holders so if
you are a long-term big goal holders
it's a very good idea to have
a little bit of your bitcoins in bit pro
the bit pro
appreciate is like 23
in the last year and a half
and so what people do is they take their
bitcoin uh and they are selling the
bitcoin for this bitcoin
uh this bit pro or they're they're
posting it somewhere like walk me
through what i if i have bitcoin and i
want to earn yield
on that bitcoin what what exactly is
happening there well
if first you have to transform your btc
in rbtc you have to have your bitcoins
on the rsk network of course
and then interacting with the platform
you meant to be pro you sent rbdc to the
system
and you mint db pro and the b pro is the
one
taking the volatility away from the
tolerance chain
and the big pro amps for and
ends because a little bit of leverage
that the dollar and chain creates on the
b pro
it earns some of the platform fees
is it earns some of the interest paid
for
by a third actor that we are going to
talk about later that
is the btcx and it earns
some of the amoc token that the the
government's
project so um
the yield in the big draw is not
warranty
for example if you buy if you mint bit
pro today
and the price of bitcoin goes down by 50
tomorrow you are going to have a haircut
probably you are if you means one
bitcoin of bit bro
and the price goes by goes down by 50
you are probably
ending up with 0.9 bitcoins
but as the dollars are
meant um in in a faster way than bitcoin
in the long term the price of bitcoins
tends to appreciate
against the dollar and in the same way
that the
bitcoin central appreciate against the
dollar
the b pro earns all that money left
in the table by the doc token holders
so if you are a long term bitcoin holder
is a very good idea to have a little bit
of bpro
and then you have this thing called
bitcoin x or btc
x which is basically a way to get
leveraged exposure
using bitcoin as collateral exactly the
btcx
is a 2x position in the price of bitcoin
um the ptcx pay for that leverage the
money that the btcx space
goes directly to the bid pro so
basically
what the principal does is it
takes the the volatility away from the
dollar and chain
and give it for free to the bit pro and
then the bit pro
sells that volatility to the btcx and
earns an interest rate in return
got it and then moc is kind of the
fourth product that you have explain
what that does
the mlc token is a governance token is
meant to govern the upgrades of the
protocol
got it and so is it fair to kind of
think of this as
a lot of what's going on in the d5 world
that's being built on top of ethereum or
binance smart chain or somewhere else
you all have been able to figure out how
to use rsk
to build it on top of bitcoin use
bitcoin as that layer one security and
then
bitcoin as the actual collateral in all
of these various products
without having to use some of the other
coins that are out there that may have
different monetary policies or different
security apparatuses
yes um one important things to notice
is that we are not forking any protocol
all the technology that we have
developed is
our technology it is well it's public
but it's developed by
us and the first thing we have
in mind developing this protocol was
robustness and security
so typically the over-collateralization
that the protocol
has is much higher than other protocols
and so the protocol is much robust
than other protocols got it and when you
start to think about kind of use cases
for this right
you're able to build a pretty compelling
product suite you're able to
kind of point to the security of bitcoin
the censorship resistant
uh but the ultimate test is in the
market and you started out earlier
talking about argentina uh and a lot of
the work that you've done over the years
of trying to educate people about
bitcoin
in argentina uh maybe kind of first
start with just like
what are the problems in argentina that
people may not be aware of in terms of
the
economy the monetary policy and some of
those macro forces
and then we can talk about how
argentinians are using uh the products
that you've built
well argentina has two really big
problems
one is inflation inflation in argentina
is like 40 to 50 percent right now
and the other project the other problem
is capital control
you cannot buy us dollars in argentina
the law there is ridiculous for example
you can manage to buy u.s dollar but you
have to pay like
160 pesos to buy
dollars and then you sell your dollars
the bank is going to give you only a
hundred dollars it's unbelievable
so people cannot buy or or use us dollar
today in argentina
but they are allowed to use stable coins
so the dollar chain is a wonderful
solution for them
people is using dollar and chain
argentina mainly
to send remittances to venezuela
there are really a few companies using
the dollar and chain
in their balance sheets
and so when you think about what you're
building
what is uh kind of the the actual
adoption
in argentina right what are people doing
with the product
um and where are you seeing kind of the
most excitement or the most uh
volume um and kind of the the largest
coalescing of users with these various
products
well first of all i have to tell you
that the protocol
is small today we have only like
uh 500 bitcoins in the protocol
started with like four bitcoin in the
protocol
the protocol is very good handling the
liquidity
so we didn't need to have
a bc putting millions of dollars to
bootstrap the protocol the liquidity of
the protocol
works always pretty well um
so the the protocol continues to grow we
have
new users every day but basically the
people using the protocol are
we have two kinds of people using the
protocol we have no coiners
using the dollar and chain um to
get away from inflation in argentina and
venezuela
and we have bitcoiners using the bit bro
to earn more satoshis
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
got it and then how do you think about
these products interacting with other
bitcoin defy uh products or kind of
ecosystems so take something like a
sovereign
um or other types of those is this
something that is they're compatible and
collaborative with each other
are they competing for users uh is it
some users will come to one uh product
or kind of platformer ecosystem for one
use case
and then other ones fulfill others just
how do you see kind of the landscape
of folks building these decentralized
financial applications on top of bitcoin
or rsk
we built the protocol thinking about
other protocols we
have the idea of collaboration instead
of competition with our
with our protocols so we build this
thinking
about protocols like sovereign or
tropicals that they can
they can use our tokens in their
protocol moreover
if you are going to i don't know go
long or short the price of bitcoin using
the sovereign
first of all it makes much more sense
for
you to go long or to go short in the big
pro
instead of the instead of the bitcoin
because if you are going
you have that little bit of leave it as
free
using the bit pro yeah it's fascinating
to me
that um you know money on chain uh
sovereign i'm sure there will be others
uh are kind of
taking a lot of the ideas that folks
have run off and built on other chains
and bringing it to bitcoin and being
able to build this in
a way that really um embodies and
embraces uh that security
um and that censorship resistant and
kind of the monetary policy etc
what's next for money on chain in terms
of both the short-term and the long-term
kind of product roadmap when asked for
questions from the audience a number of
people were asking
just around how do you think about the
continued development of the ecosystem
and what other products you're either
working on
or could potentially work on over the
long term well we are
in the mbb version
of every part of the protocol
so there there is a lot of new
functionality
that are coming to manual chain for
example
one of those functionalities is that you
are going to be able to earn
interest in your dialogue chain inside
the protocol
another feature that is coming
is that you are going to be able to lock
your bitcoin
and get a loan in dollar and chain
um you will be able to go
long 2x 5x 10x 15x and you will
be able to go shorts also so there is a
lot of things coming for
money and check when you think about
the money on chain governance model
there's a couple of folks who asked me
to get you to describe it in kind of the
simplest terms possible
how does that governance model work and
then how does the moc token fit into the
governance model
okay the first thing that i have to
clarify and
make sure everybody understand is that
the protocol is not fully decentralized
today
we are in the in the process of going
100
centralized to going 100 decentralized
so the mlc token is the token that
allows changes in the protocol today
the changes are still centralized i
think we need like
two four to six weeks more to go
completely decentralized
but after we go completely centralized
there is no way to change the protocol
without
mlc token holders approval
got it and so when you start to think
about uh how that governance model will
evolve over time um do you need to get
to the full decentralization and that's
kind of where you have the full utility
and power of the governance model
um or do you see feel like there's a lot
of kind of importance and value on the
governance model today even though it
might not be 100 decentralized yet
well um today
you have the full benefits in the mlc
token in in the sense that if you
take your mlc in the protocol you are
going to get
every penny from that the protocol
generates
but um as i told you it's not
fully decentralized today but why we
need decentralization
because we need censorship resistance
that is
why because we want the centralization
there is no
other reason to go fully decentralized
just to be fully censorship resistance
got it and so when you think about that
trade-off between starting out 100
centralized and then moving to 100
decentralized do you feel like that is
the
natural evolution or the natural path
that
every decentralized system is gonna have
to go through like you can't just launch
and be decentralized on day one or do
you think there is a path that some
people
uh for whatever reason who want to do
that could actually do it from a
technical perspective or from an
implementation perspective
well um i think they fully decentralized
to fully decentralized is the the way
that make
more sense if you think about bitcoin
bitcoin started 100
centralized bitcoin started with all the
code and all the decisions
in satoshi with all the mining power in
satoshi and all the coins
in satoshi and from that point it
started the path to the centralization
the same
things have to happen in manual chain
and other protocols
it's possible to start a protocol fully
decentralized from the beginning
probably but that will be very
inefficient
it's inefficient probably actually very
difficult to do as well right
to some degree uh j just how would you
coordinate that
and if there's coordination like that
there's likely some level of
centralization anyways
um so makes uh makes sense what to use
been the biggest lesson in building uh
money on chain and kind of this suite of
products that you now have today
has there been a major surprise or
something you've learned along the way
that you think is valuable for people to
know
um the biggest lesson i don't know
we we thought that it was that it would
be
much easier to to to
get the funds to make the project
um we started at the beginning of the
crypto winter
uh being argentinian that was really
tough
why why specifically being argentinian
why did that make it more tough
well i don't know maybe
i think that at the beginning
we had no credibility because we were
from latin america and trying to
make the thing that everybody was
thinking it was impossible
so it was very hard at the beginning
yeah
makes uh makes sense what's the one
thing that uh people misunderstand about
argentina
um or the economy or the population
there
um i think that people in the united
states
and europe um
cannot get the idea that stable coins
from argentinian are are
almost like a matter of life and debt
because um you have the dollar or the
agro
you can trust in the banks in latin
america people cannot trust in the bank
my father loses the savings of all his
life like
three times in his last in his lifetime
and we have like 40 50
sometimes more percent inflation that
you cannot even imagine how it's like to
live with that um i think that
people tend to think that stable coins
are
very interesting to trade or to
um i don't know to play with uh
lending protocols but for people in
nature in america
uh stephen coins are really really
serious an important thing
yeah it uh it's very sobering talking to
somebody who kind of lives through
something like that in terms of the
importance of the technology
uh but also kind of the the better life
the better world the better kind of
financial position
that can usher in for somebody who
understands these technologies and can
leverage them
uh to their benefit um i always ask
everybody the same three questions to
finish up and then you'll get to ask me
one question at the end
but before we do that where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about money on chain
well you can go to our page
moneyonchain.com
then you have a community link and you
can join us in telegram or discord
or you can follow us on twitter awesome
all right first question what's the most
important book that you've ever read
uh very good questions the most
important book i ever read
it calls lost work here i never remember
the author
but i born in a
catholic family one day
my father gave me
that book as a gift and that book
really opens my mind now i am agnostic
what is the thing that drove uh kind of
opening your mind or expanding your
thought process
sorry what was the thing that you took
from the book that really kind of opened
your mind or forced you to expand your
thinking
oh the book tells the history
of the church and the corruption
there oh the corruption of the church
got it yeah that that is uh uh
all around the world uh a very unique
situation
uh that i think many people uh were
taken by surprise uh regardless of your
religion or
which uh kind of controversy um has
popped up
the second question is about your sleep
schedule so i've got my friends over at
eight sleep
uh i got one of these um thermal
regulated beds basically i can make it
hot or cold um and i used to sleep like
five or six hours but now i sleep eight
or nine i turn it super cold like an
ice cube uh and i'm a full convert to
the sleep religion
i'm obsessed with making sure i get my
eight or nine hours of sleep
so much to the point of where i
literally beg them to let me invest in
their company
what is your sleep schedule like and how
has that evolved over the years
um i
tend to sleep between seven
and nine hours um
i think that that is very important for
my mind to work correctly
um i used to
sleep less a few years ago but
i don't know now i'm sleeping every day
from seven to nine hours that's good as
you get older you start to realize hey
that sleeping is important
it makes sense it's important
my last question for you is a little bit
more fun and you get to ask me one is
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
oh that's a very good question i don't
know i'm
sure that there is aliens out there
somewhere but i'm not sure if they
have visited us because the
the universe is very big and the
distance are
very huge so um
[Music]
definitely i believe there is aliens out
there but i don't know if they
have been with us or not i need evidence
i uh i tend to agree with your uh
analysis
that uh they are likely to exist but
very unlikely to uh to have come to
earth
already who knows what will happen in
the future but uh i don't know if we
have that evidence yet
what one question do you have for me to
uh to finish this up here
um do you like our protocol
i think it's very intelligent uh and i
think the thing that uh if you said to
me what's the one thing
that sticks out to me uh about money on
chain is
the ability to take ideas that i think
you i and many other people
agree are important uh for a financial
system whether it's stability and value
whether it's earning yield
governance things like that and build it
on top of the most secure blockchain the
most decentralized blockchain
uh but still to take a lot of the
innovation that's occurred
across the entire industry right whether
it's somebody in the bitcoin community
or somebody on in one of the other
communities that has built
uh some of this technology and being
able to incorporate it
in a very uh kind of unique and very um
adherent to the bitcoin ethos way so
being non-custodial being able to
have that smart contract capability but
still doing it all with the security
um and kind of the decentralization of
that base chain
i think is just a unique value
proposition and so most people who
listen to the podcast will know that you
know i'm a big fan of all sorts of
uh decentralized financial applications
being built on top of bitcoin
i don't think that it's necessarily uh
kind of a winner take all or a zero-sum
game i think there'll be coexistence
of decentralized financial applications
across various ecosystems
i'm personally most interested in the
ones on top of bitcoin because of some
of the non-economic
um you know kind of advantages that they
bring in in terms of freedom
and censorship resistance etc uh but it
seems like you know you
sovereign um the rsk folks are just
pioneering
uh a very unique part of the market that
uh my hope is more and more people start
to pay attention to learn about start
using the products
uh and kind of eventually become
advocates for uh
over time okay great
all right so moneyonchain.com is where
we can send people to learn more
sorry moneyonchain.com is where we can
send people to learn more
yes absolutely manualchain.com and you
can follow us
in twitter at manual chain
okay awesome listen max thank you so
much for taking the time to do this i
really really enjoyed it
i'm a big fan of what you guys are
building and we'll definitely have to
have you come back on as you guys get
more progress
and get more products launched over time
thank you for inviting me